carlos sa dans le passé sa deuxième
nuit en prison le terroriste mise en
examen hier par le juge bruguière a
été placé sous mandat de dépôt
carlos cp détenus sous le régime
ordinaire à la prison de la santé mais
pour ce prisonnier de l'ordinaire les
syndicats de gardiens de prison de mende
plus de moyens claude son père et
jean-paul guilloteau
1 dps un détenu particulièrement
surveillé
carlos serait bien de passer cette
deuxième nuit à la maison d'arrêt de
la santé à paris
troisième division dans un quartier
spécial le quartier d'isolement
carlos cp est au rez-de-chaussée au
deuxième étage se trouve le docteur
garetta ripoll tout
tout est fait pour que les détenus ne
se rencontrent
il faut donc que telle personne et sur
la séance non pas des puces gravées en
permanence donc pourtant lorsque
elle est donc pour la mesure d'isolement
% à chaque fois qu'il fait au moment de
sa cellule doit être accompagnée par
rapport à nos collègues que je n'ai
cité donc à partir de là le 4 % sur
l'exemption demandée pour simplement
une personne ça fait beaucoup quand on
sait ce qui a énormément de
développer encore notre s'occuper ceci
dit ça fait partie de notre boulot
simplement il me manque des effectifs et
c'est ce qu'on réclame depuis des
années et au-delà c'est le point de
structure pour cent et ce que nous
souhaitons depuis toujours des
établissements spécialisés pour
garder effectivement ce genre de
d'individus parti tôt dans la journée
par la société et notre job c'est de
garder et de garder en toute sécurité
pour le reste carlos ce pays soumis à
un régime de détention d'image
la radio-télévision cigarettes
boissons non alcoolisées
en revanche il est seule en promenade il
peut déjeuner à la cantine mais on
aurait pu des canucks
deux fois par semaine il recevra la
visite d'un médecin qui peut émettre
un avis sur le maintien nous non on nous
a demandé
selon le ministère de la justice la
santé orco toutes les garanties de
sécurité l avantage d'être proche du
palais de justice carlos sainz le rebond
qui respecte jusqu'à son procès